ja für Verwirrung sagt mir wieder Karl
Lauterbach immer hat er die Impfpflicht
hochgehalten hartnäckig verteidigt nur
so beenden wir die Pandemie jetzt will
er die Impfpflicht in Krankenhäusern
alten und Pflegeheimen auslaufen lassen
und das hat er irgendwie seltsam
begründet da schauen wir mal kurz rein
es gab Protest aber das war keine
Grundlage hier für die Änderung es ist
eine reine epidemiologische Überlegung
die Impfung schützt nicht mehr vor der
Ansteckung und wenn sie nicht mehr vor
der Ansteckung schützt dann gibt's auch
keinen Grund mehr in diesen
Einrichtungen trotzdem bleibt es
natürlich dabei die impfungsschutz sehr
gut Moment der Impfstoff schützt nicht
gegen die Ansteckungen noch vor ein paar
Wochen hat er zum Stadt der ins Kampagne
gesagt die Impfung schütze vor der
Ansteckung Herrmann glauben sie den
Gesundheitsminister